explain to me about Led Zeppelin you
seem to not want to give them their due
I give them their do one of our
reviewers I forget who in the early days
when we I was losing control I wasn't
paying attention record section we had
some reviewers who were really nasty to
me they would get a record they weren't
reviewing the record they'd use it
they'd go use as an excuse to get some
nasty riff of their own that had nothing
to do with the record and take it you
know take a group part about their
clothes or put they put in the Allen
jacket and it wasn't a review of the
record and it wasn't freaking fair to
the artists who had worked so hard on it
and who deserved legitimate respect and
criticism and if you didn't like
anything something it'd be better say so
which was one of the things we do and
and it wasn't fair to the audience our
readers do you try to
apologize to Jimmy Page or Robert Plant
I mean do you go and try and say look we
had a guy who you know for whatever
reason had to stick up his ass and uh
you know look uh we we recognize you now
but they couldn't let go of it is what
you're saying I don't know if we
formally tried to apologize or it went
through a circuitous route to the record
coming to the pr person to them or
whatever but they weren't going to take
no and they were they weren't going to
take an apology and furthermore they're
the biggest group in the world so you
know screw those guys in San Francisco
all in right um in the end a peace was
brokered by Cameron Crowe and they let
us in and we went on the boat with them
and all seven the other Jimmy though
showed up at the he waited two or three
weeks to do it he showed up the photo
shoot with a bouquet of dead roses to
give to me
so in other words that's the beauty of
Cameron Crowe yeah Led Zeppelin doesn't
like you but they'll deal with Cameron
Crowe and from your point of view like
fine you can hate me but guess what I'm
gonna get the story through Cameron Crow
I'm gonna send you the nicest most
Charming wonderful kid you will never be
able to say bad to give out of him
by the way to Cameron told me that he
said that Jimmy Perry is not I'm only
mad about the review but that I had
stolen his girlfriend as long as this
girl I don't know I don't know I like
this story I like the sound of it yeah
and that's why I repeated here but I
don't remember such a thing
foreign